Donald Trump has had the luxury of being
the owner and boss basically since the
beginning of his career and one of the
great things about being the owner and
boss is that in a sense you can't get
fired now I know that if you're the CEO
of a publicly-traded company and there's
a Board of Directors you might be the
founder and you might be the majority
shareholder majority the the plurality
owner rather not majority shareholder
but you might still be forced to step
down as CEO for example and there are
some cases in which you can be the
founder and the boss and still get fired
but in many situations outside of
publicly traded companies you're
effectively immune from getting fired if
you're the one in charge I can't be
fired from the David Pakman show
for example I'm the majority shareholder
there's no board of directors every paid
member could quit every viewer could
stop watching we could end up with
effectively no show I could just be
sitting here doing videos that nobody
sees but I can't be fired in a sense and
that is not typical in most jobs your
behavior on and off the job can get you
fired and I was thinking over the
weekend that Donald Trump's behavior at
any other job where he is not the owner
of the company or the person in charge
would have absolutely gotten him fired
by now Donald Trump has publicly
insulted countless world leaders sort of
equivalent to being our business
partners we can say in a sense if
anybody ranging from a low-level
employee to the CEO were to publicly
insult their company's clients or their
customers or their partners in the way
that Donald Trump has insulted the
leaders of other world countries they
would have been fired by now the highest
law enforcement agencies in the country
did an investigation into Donald Trump
and they found substantial evidence of
criminality on eight of 14 possible
obstruction counts at any other job
those results from a criminal
investigation would obviously get you
fired and most people would also be
indicted and facing prison time right
now but Trump's the boss or the owner or
whatever role he has as president of the
states of america he's apparently immune
there as well and then there's a whole
other sort of angle on this George
Conway who's an attorney and the husband
of Kellyanne Conway who is one of Donald
Trump's closest advisors George Conway
is a big Trump opponent and he pointed
out something else which is that someone
having the apparent
mental health issues that Donald Trump
is having would also have been let go
from any other job based on his behavior
tweeting over the weekend quote you're
not presidential at all period you're
mentally unwell you engage in bizarre
irrational self-defeating behavior which
prompts criticism of you which triggers
more bizarre irrational self-defeating
behavior you would have been fired from
any other job by now Trump's behavior is
the type that would get the bosses
together to say this person needs to go
let's figure out how to get them out of
here
with the least amount of drama possible
and we can actually go further if
anybody exhibited Donald Trump's
behavior during the campaign in the
hiring process for a job they would
never even get hired in the first place
and this is what happens when instead of
a three-person hiring committee
including the CEO someone from HR and
the supervisor gets to decide who to
hire when it's instead left up to the
American people American voters sixty
million of whom are right-wing
Republicans this is exactly what you end
up with over the weekend I was talking
to a friend who's dealing with a very
similar situation at work they have a
co-worker who started writing outrageous
aggressive emails including to their
supervisors talking back to management
straight up saying they're not going to
be doing certain things because as they
see it it doesn't make sense to do it
and telling the supervisors that taking
offense to anything that said around
them and management is trying to figure
out we need to get rid of this person
but we also need to do it in a way that
is not going to create even more
absolute and total chaos that's the
distinction with Donald Trump any normal
person who
caved during the hiring process the way
Donald Trump behaved during the campaign
would not have been hired any person who
behaved at their job the way Donald
Trump has behaved since becoming
president of the United States would
have been fired but the one advantage is
we can just vote Trump out okay people
can just go vote and Trump has to leave
period in January of 2021 and my ask of
you is the following as atrocious and
disastrous as Donald Trump is we
shouldn't forget that Trump is an effect
not a cause now yeah Donald Trump's
presidency has caused a lot of bad
things he's ruined relationships with
allies he's weaponized ignorance
he's weaponized hypocrisy but Trump's
presidency is the result of the last 30
years not a cause in and of itself so
remember that getting rid of Trump
doesn't actually solve the problem
although it's still something that we
should do but also understand the sort
of proximate causes that led to Donald
Trump which is exactly what I want to
talk about next on the show because it's
so important and a lot of people are
missing the boat on this today's program
is sponsored in part by zip recruiter
because finding a new job is a lot of
work what if you had your own personal
recruiter to help you find a better job
zip recruiters technology can do that
for you download the zip recruiter job
search app let it know what kind of jobs
you're interested in and it's technology
will start to do the work for you the
zip recruiter app finds jobs you like
puts your profile in front of employers
who may be looking for somebody like you
if an employer likes your profile zip
recruiter lets you know so that if
you're interested in the job you can
apply no wonder
zip recruiter is the number one rated
job search app and based on a
third-party survey 7 out of 10 people
who found a new job on zip recruiter
increased their salaries
download the free zip recruiter job
search app today and let the power of
technology work for you don't wait the
sooner you download the
free zip recruiter job search app the
sooner it can help you find a better job